this is a corkscrew dive it's one of the
most difficult maneuvers you can pull
off in a helicopter and one that Tom
Cruise learned to fly himself it was his
own real-life impossible mission because
Ethan Hunt and his team are back
it's another race against time after an
operation gone wrong
what hell is he doing find it best not
to hook crews put in about three months
of solid days in the classroom and in
the air to gain the skills that he
needed he came to helicopter school at
Airbus in Texas so we did too to find
out what's involved by taking some
classes and taking the controls Cruz has
made a name for himself as a Hollywood
daredevil doing many of his own
extremely risky scenes back since the
mission impossible franchise started in
1996 but this is extreme even for him
this is the H 125 a lighter class of
helicopter this isn't just any old H 1
to 5 this is one that was actually new
this is the one that was used in the
movie you're absolutely correct Matt
Evans my instructor a super experienced
pilot himself breaks down how he'd
approached a corkscrew dives a move like
that would have to be very carefully
planned out initially you'd start with
nosing the nose over that would initiate
the descent roll gently into a turn hold
the turn as you come down watching the
rotor rpm because if the g-forces
increase that's going to want to spin
the rotor rpm very very fast that can in
itself cause a lot of trouble for both
the pilot and the aircraft itself so
you'd have to limit there by constantly
keeping your hands on the controls
watching what's going on both inside and
outside will taneous li got that not
sure I have but training starts in the
classroom much of becoming a pilot is
theory it's book learning and exams it
can take a week of eight-hour days just
to get the basics and then there are
tests the next step is a
state-of-the-art simulator the place
that you can make mistakes without dying
it's surprisingly realistic now it
replicates the feel of flying faithfully
with legs that jog it up and down and
wraparound screens inside
Oh God Matt's making it look easy
this maneuver is pretty close to the
pork screw dive helicopters are
particularly challenging to fly because
there's a pilot you have to be
constantly engaged with the controls
right hand on the cyclic left hand on
the collective feet on the pedals move
one and you have to adjust all the
others - as a novice I grip the controls
too hard and my adjustments just aren't
subtle enough even when I try to fly
straight and level we drift it's a lot
harder than it looks at the end of that
flight and ready for a break but next
things are getting real it's time to
take to the air and see how much I've
remembered I'm in the pilot's seat front
right but Matt is alongside with dual
controls and to be clear he's the one
flying here
this is incredible I know it doesn't
look dramatic but trust me this is
stressful I thought I'd be tempted to
just try out some maneuvers but focusing
on level flight is enough to make me
sweat I feel like you can spend time in
the simulator and in the classroom and
those things are obviously important but
there's nothing like being out here and
seeing real life going on below us my
hands are actually a little bit tight
just from holding these controls now I'm
even doing anything
I'm definitely not trying at all screwed
oh and neither is Matt it's not only
taxing on the pilots but also the
aircraft so it's not something you do on
a routine training flight we can get
pretty close here Matt is pointing us
straight down with a lurch that feels
like a roller coaster
the terrain terrain warning means please
don't crash into the rapidly approaching
ground I feel like I understand why
crews wanted to fly his own stunts it's
the only way to make this look fully
real
the next challenge for the Mission
Impossible crew was how to show the
audience that crews really is the pilot
one most aerial chasers you'll see from
a helicopter
we don't usually turn the cameras in so
we've developed these rigs over the last
couple months well we can basically hard
mount cameras to show that Ethan Hunt is
flying the helicopter without anybody
else every camera position has been
designed so that you can see that tom is
doing everything himself
all that rigging has already been
removed from the helicopter
eventually this one will be sold to the
next customer we'll be getting a bit of
Hollywood history but one that's been
fully serviced and restored after that
demanding flying but the real movie
magic came through dedication and focus
Tom Cruise developed the skills of a
pilot who's flown thousands of hours and
a very short amount of time it's a
reminder of just how much further I'd
have to go to qualify as opposed to just
ride along so someone who doesn't have
any sort of flight training previously
it would probably take them for a very
very talented coordinated individual two
to three months and that's at 6 to 8
hours of theory per day and a hardcore
three hours of flying up to 1500 pilots
and trainees come through this facility
every year honing their skills for the
police fire and medical services or for
military work Tom Cruise just happens to
be the most famous amongst them and the
one who's impossible mission will be
watched by millions